95% of Who We Are by the age of 35 is
programmed is that true I think if we
Define a habit is a redundant set of
automatic unconscious thoughts behaviors
and emotions that's acquired through
repetition The Habit is when you've done
something so many times that your body
now knows how to do it better than your
conscious mind then it's programmed
subconsciously so then when the body
knows how to do it better than the
conscious mind then for the most part
the greatest habit we have to break is
the habit of being ourselves right so
there's a principal Neuroscience that
says that nerve cells that fire together
wire together if you keep thinking the
same way uh if you keep making the same
choices if you keep doing the same
things if you keep reproducing the same
experiences and feeling the same
emotions your biology begins to become
hardwired in a sense it becomes
programmed hey it's EV Carmichael and I
make these videos because I need them
because I want to wake up every single
day and get pushed by somebody who's
doing a lot more than me and in watching
their videos it in inspires me to be
bolder to have more courage and go chase
down the life of my dreams and I hope it
does the same for you so today let's
learn to shift our identity and attract
success with Dr Joe dispenser
enjoy in order to change uh something to
arrive at a new vision of your future if
you were wanted to arrive at a new goal
or New Vision of your future you'd have
to change something about yourself in
order to get there and you'd have to
change the way you think the way you act
and the way you feel when you begin to
become
conscious of those unconscious thoughts
so conscious that you don't let them
slip by your awareness unnoticed or
unchecked by you if you catch yourself
speaking in a limited way or um you you
become conscious that you're behaving in
a certain way in a
habit and you can notice or pay
attention to how you're feeling then
you're no longer the program now your
consciousness
observing the program you're only
unconscious when you're in the program
and so to change then is to become so
conscious that you don't don't go
unconscious again and in a sense that is
consciousness that is really the puppet
master that really decides who we want
to be I think the biggest problem uh is
that people lose their free will uh to a
set of programs and so their body is
basically um programmed into predictable
future based on what they done in the
past so to change then to change that
habituation takes an enormous amount of
energy an enormous amount of awareness
rule number two is remember your vision
wake up every day how bad do you want it
how bad do you want your dream it's so
much easier to forget that Vision than
to remember it right so if you're going
to remember it you got to keep it alive
in your mind how do you keep it alive in
your mind you you disconnect from your
environment you close your eyes you play
music in the background you get sit your
body down and it's got to pee and it's
got to eat and it's got to just just sit
down for a few minutes like training a
dog like stay when I say it's time to
get up we get up don't be thinking about
what's going to happen in your day you
already know what going to happen don't
think what happened yesterday you
already know that get in the present
moment and say who do I want to be when
I open my eyes who do I want to be today
what would greatness look like how how
would I how would one day one shot one
lifetime what would an abundant person
do let me rehearse that with my eyes
closed let me remind myself who I don't
want to be let me remind myself who do I
want to be let's not get up leis until
we get into that until we are to where
the tennis ball hits The Sweet Spot when
you go oh I'm ready for the day now now
game on now if you can maintain that
modified State of Mind and Body the
entire day without defaulting by seeing
someone or doing something stay in that
state the experiment still continues and
you're changing your energy doesn't
happen in 2 days you're not that good
right that's it you're not that good
keep
prac people who show up the for the 21
weeks in a row this woman 21 weeks in a
row the end of the 21 weeks she knew it
boom her whole life changed boom was it
21 days worth ask her the experiment she
was just changing the process rule
number three is synchronize your energy
I think we've all experienced those
synchronicities where you're thinking
about something or you have an intention
and all of a sudden you start to see
reality kind of can form itself around
you in some way and you're not going
anywhere to get it uh somehow it seems
to be coming to you and there's a very
direct correlation between energy and
reality so when you start to synchronize
your energy to a possibility that exists
in the quantum field and you have a
coherent brain there's a very very
specific signal that we can send out
that's very very C coherent and
clear and when we match that brain
coherence with heart coherence it is the
heart that acts as a magnet and draws
the experience back to us so the thought
being electrical charge and the feeling
being the magnetic charge and how you
think and how you feel broadcasts
information into the quantum field and I
think whatever we broadcast into the
field is our experiment with Destiny so
we either create from the field or we
create from matter and if we create from
matter as bodies local in space and time
and three-dimensional reality we have to
move through space to get what we want
we have to move back and forth to work
and drive there uh to manifest our
dreams and in creating a
three-dimensional reality takes time and
it takes
energy sometimes uh people get so lost
in reality they forget what they're
dream dreams were because there's too
much time between cause the thought and
effect the experience and that's what
separation does in three-dimensional
reality creating from the field and
getting Beyond yourself your
associations to everything physical and
known and being able to enter
through a small door the eye of the
needle the quantum field passing through
that eye of the needle as pure
Consciousness and connecting to a field
and teaching people how to create from
the field instead of from matter
connected to that unified field uh to
Source energy when they create from
source and they're Connected To Source
and source is the cause that creates
matter the effect if we create from
Source connected to it from the field
instead of from matter we don't have to
go anywhere now to get what we want we
begin to draw the experiences to us so
by combining
heart coherence with brain coherence now
we have a Wi-Fi signal and all we have
to do is synchronize our energy to some
intention with some emotion and tune in
to the energy of the future and the
longer you're conscious of this energy
the more you draw your future to you and
if you keep practicing it every day it's
going to become familiar to you and all
of a sudden that will be your natural
energy and when you change your energy
you change your life and the more
coherent the signatures
electromagnetically the more refined The
Experience uh we have also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is reframe your
reality being victimized by a
circumstance in your life literally
means that that that event that
circumstance that person that condition
is actually causing you you to feel
emotionally and think in terms of
memories equal to that circumstance and
that circumstances actually changes your
state of being so you're thinking the
same way and you're feeling the same way
and your response to the environment is
the same we can guarantee that your life
is going to stay the same because you're
the same you ask that person why are you
unhappy why are you frustrated why are
you sad they'll say the this condition
this is this person is actually making
me feel and think this way well anything
that makes us feel and think a certain
way that we don't think we have any
control over for the most part we're
victims so we're as a species become
victimized by the conditions in our life
and it's the environment then that is
controlling the way we feel and the way
we think so the idea is if you can
change the way you think and change the
way you feel could you begin to produce
outcomes or effects in your life that
caus you to believe that you're the
creator of your life instead of the
victim of your life which means then you
would have to think greater than that
circumstance and you would have to feel
differently in the presence of that
circumstance and if you truly could and
begin to create an outcome the
synchronicity the Serendipity the
coincidence that happens in your life
you're going to pay attention to what
you did and you're going to realize that
on some level you had a hand in that you
know that you are a participant in that
our interest is to teach people how to
to to reverse that
process every person every circumstance
every condition every place every object
that you own is mapped neurologically in
your brain so your brain is a record of
the past it's it's an artifact the
repository of everything you've learned
intellectually or experienced end
products of experience are called
emotions the memories that we have in
our life produces familiar emotions or
our resp responds to anybody that we
know in our life there's a neurological
Network for your boss for your coworker
for your ex and for most people their
their their interaction in the
environment is causing their environment
to control their thinking or their
personal reality is controlling their
personality so our interest to see is so
well if your personality is made of how
you think how you act and how you feel
is it possible if I begin to change the
way I think change the way I act and
change the way I I feel should my life
change and because I'm changing and so
the interest for us then is to be able
to meet the challenges and conditions in
our life from a greater level of
Consciousness and and not be victimized
uh by those circumstances but to take
time and and to review how you're going
to think how you're going to act and how
you're going to feel that's
meditation and review how you're not
going to think you know how you're not
going to act and how you're not going to
feel it just turn out that tends to be
95% of who we are those unconscious
programs so it's so much easier to
forget than to remember because it's the
majority of who we are you know after a
certain point in our life so changing
that process the overcoming process of
that same self somehow begins to produce
effects in people's lives and that's
that's kind of the exciting part about
being a creator of your life rule number
five is Master your thoughts the
majority of the thoughts that we think
every single day are the same thoughts
as we thought
yesterday and in fact 90% of them are
and the same thoughts leading to the
same choices the same choices leading to
the same behaviors the same behaviors
creating the same experiences and the
same experiences producing the same
feelings and
emotions begins to cause our
biology to become very similar very same
and the repetition of that and firing
and wiring then creates automatic
program in the brain and body and 95% of
who we are is a state of unconscious or
subconscious programs where we've done
something so many times that the body
now can actually do it automatically
without the conscious mind if you truly
wanted to change and you understood that
your personality creates your personal
reality and your personality is made up
of how you think how you act and how you
feel and the present personality who's
listening to this call has created the
present personal reality called their
life that means if they wanted to create
a new personal reality a new life they
would have to begin to change their
personality they'd have to change
themselves and most people then try to
create a new personal reality as the
same personality it doesn't work so then
if you're sitting in your meditation and
you ask yourself the question who do I
want to be when I open my eyes what is
the greatest expression of
myself and you said okay let me remind
myself of how I no longer want to think
you know the thoughts
like whatever it's too hard I'll never
change I'll never get what I want let me
become so
conscious of those unconscious thoughts
that I wouldn't let that thought slip by
my awareness today unnoticed by me and
program my autonomic nerve system in
specific outcome and then if you said
how would I want to speak today how do I
want to act how do I want to behave and
you reminded yourself how you weren't
going to act and how you weren't going
to behave and you became conscious of
those unconscious habits to such a
degree you wouldn't go unconscious and
behave in the same way that's when
you're no longer the program now you're
Consciousness observing the program if
you said when am I when does my energy
drop when when what do I feel when I
feel those typical familiar emotions
what are they uh so let me name them
just so I'm so aware of them that when
my energy drops I can catch myself in
that moment and not return back to the
same familiar emotions and cause my body
to believe it's back in the past and we
can't see a new future from the past so
that process then is what I call getting
beyond the old self and it's a
disentangling from the program the word
meditation means to become familiar with
so as you sit there and become familiar
with those states of Mind and Body you
begin to objectify your subjective self
now now you are you are becoming so
aware of the unconscious programs you
won't go unconscious and that's the
first step to change and then what if
you said what thoughts do I want to fire
and wire to my brain what thoughts do I
want to put my attention behind and
begin to install the new circuitry the
new hardware and if I keep my attention
on it and I fire and wire those thoughts
it's going to begin to become a software
program and that's going to be the new
voice in my head that's going to be the
voice that's telling me the new program
that you can that it is possible rule
number six is believe I think that the
greatest belief that you could have is
the belief in yourself and when you
believe in yourself you believe in
possibilities and when you believe in
possibilities you have to believe in
yourself so uh people that enter this
work uh come with a certain amount of
chronic disbelief that they could
actually change their life or change
their health condition when you see the
scientific
research that uh in seven days a novice
meditator their biology literally looks
like they're in a different life and
they're in a ballroom and there's
nothing very special about a ballroom
I've been to thousands of ballrooms that
the environment isn't that stimulating
that those changes are coming from
within you see the data and you look at
how cancer cells actually the energy and
cancer cells when you take the plasma of
meditators advanced meditators and you
subject that plasma to all kinds of
cancer
cells 70% of the mitochondrial function
actually diminishes in the cancer cell
cancer cells love to multiply and they
love to move you take energy out of the
cancer cell you're taking life out of
the cancer cell when people see that
data it gives them hope it gives them
the idea that it's possible now when
someone stands on the stage with stage
four cancer that has spread to their
bones to the uterus to their lungs to
the liver uh to all the tissues of their
body and you ask any physician who's
seen stage 4 cancer in Bones it's very
unlikely you're going to see a reversal
and you see the person stand on the
stage and tell their story and it's not
glamorous it's a real life story and
there's no evidence of cancer in any of
her tissues any longer no cancer in her
bones the pet scans show that there's a
complete
reversal that's the 4minute mile that's
the person speaking the truth and
invariably somebody in the audience is
examining that person's story and
they're thinking if that person can do
it I can do it as well and R number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is change your brain
waves the whole purpose of meditation is
to get beyond the analytical mind and
what separates the conscious mind from
the subconscious mind is the analytical
mind and so we'll talk about that in a
minute but we teach people how to create
coherent brains and of course we also
teach them and they understand that when
they're resentful or they're impatient
or they're frustrated their heart also
beats incoherently as well as well so
then is it possible then to train them
to regulate their autonomic nervous
system by changing their brain waves and
by changing their heart coherence so
then they can begin to transform
themselves and transform matter and
that's kind of the model that we use
next slide quick little overview on
brain waves here look at the top one
there it says beta brain waves you can
see they're pretty fast your brain's job
is to create meaning or coherence
between what's going on in your outer
world and what's going on in your inner
world most people function in beta brain
wave patterns when they're wake and they
wake up in their morning and their brain
starts making serotonin they start to
use their senses and they're integrating
everything through their senses and the
brains trying to process all that
information into meaning so they're
sitting they're feeling pain they're
tired they're hungry they have the light
on uh they're doing a few things and the
brain's got to deal with all that
information so brain waves in the
thinking brain are pretty quick when you
close your eyes and you uh eliminate
your external environment as an example
your brain kind of slows down in brain
waves because because it's processing
less information so now you're in Alpha
and Alpha instead of the outer World
being more real the inner world starts
becoming more real when your body falls
asleep and your mind is awake you move
into what's called Theta brain wave
patterns that's a good place to be
because if you've conditioned your body
to be the mind and your body's asleep
and your mind is awake that means it's
no longer the mind and you can fall
right into some pretty quick changes and
reprogram those automatic programs Delta
of course is restorative sleep and we
won't have time to get into gamma but I
call gamma super Consciousness or super
awareness that's when the brain is
aroused but instead of because of some
predator or some threat in the
environment the brain is aroused because
the sympathetic nervous system is
switched on and it's releasing energy
instead of out of the body up into the
brain and the person's really has all
their attention on the inner
experience I have a question regarding
the use of cell phones and how it
generates dopamine and how is it in in
some way affects our uh meditations our
ability to meditate excellent
question the question was to repeat it I
want to know the effects of cell phones
uh on our brains and how it affects our
dopamine levels and and you know I I
raised three kids and you know kids use
technology and I was saying this when I
was talking to some of you this morning
over a cup of coffee
that that if your children are using
cell phones for information and
basically we are information that's all
we are and they're they're they're
accessing information the way they do
and they're using their cell phones in
all kinds of ways for
stimulation there should be a period of
time where they were able to set it down
just like for
you and if you can't break your romance
with your cell
phone then it owns you would you agree
because that's what keeps you connected
to networks socially that kind of social
Consciousness is is is is maintained
through networks
and it feeds us because we love tribe We
Love Culture we love connection but it's
it it's got to be done with discernment
so what happens for people
is if they if they can't break from it
and go from a narrow Focus to a broad
Focus like get out and nature go hike go
get on a boat I mean open your focus and
look at the sunset you don't think that
creates Alpha in your brain it does
nature does that the Resonance of the
hum's constant is the exact 7.8
frequency of Alpha Brain W and training
us to
connection so when when they've done the
research on on cell phones the video
gaming to start with they said to these
kids Hey listen um here's how it's going
to go you guys want to make some money
what do you think the kid said yeah
let's make some money yeah I said okay
we're going to get you involved in a
video game and then we're going to ring
a bell and you have 5 Seconds to stop if
you stop in 5 seconds we'll give you a
dollar and we're just going to go as
long as you what however long I went do
you know that none of the children none
of them were able to stop that's how
that's how addictive it is so the
research shows then
that when you begin to blow somebody up
or you shoot someone or you get a text
you know that's important text to you
there's a release of dopamine in your
brain the pleasure chemical the reward
chemical is released but if you're
overdoing it and you're playing a lot of
video gaming and you're blowing
something something up or blowing
someone up or breaking through some
level or doing something the reward
systems are being activated in your
brain and you start releasing too much
dopamine all at
once and that burst of dopamine into the
brain is more than the receptor sites
have to handle it you understand what
I'm saying come on so then the over
amount of dopamine is not being absorbed
by those receptors The receptors close
down it's too much they become
desensitized it's like living with a
spouse that always yells at you they got
to yell a little louder to get your
attention the next time need a little
bit more now to turn it on the next time
does that make sense so then the
pleasure C the pleasure centers start
recalibrating to a higher and higher
level it takes more now to turn them on
you do a bigger burst to get them
stimulated are you with me still so the
the pleasure centers start recalibrating
to such a high level that now the person
needs the game needs the phone to feel
something to make that feeling because
in the absence of any
stimulation they experience a loss of
pleasure you understand what I'm saying
they become desensitized to pleasure so
a walk with your dog go tell a kid to go
see their
grandmother watch a sunset just way too
slow they're overstimulated are you with
me still and that's called adidon you
can't find pleasure from anything
ad hedonia I believe that it's not
matter that is emitting a field I think
it's the field that creates matter so
when you change the field you change
matter and the science behind that is
very supportive so my ability to
articulate it my research that I've done
since then and the studies that I've
done uh in additional education has
helped me to be able to put together a
formula uh and that
formula uh in this present time is is
producing very dramatic changes in
people's lives and health and let's do
gratitude appreciation kindness uh
thankfulness and let's let's start
self-regulating and and we put heart
rate monitors on them to make sure that
they were doing that at uh 10 minutes a
day for 3 days in a row right three
times a day at the end of 3 days 3 and
1/2 days we remeasured everything their
IGA levels went up
50% 50% that's that means that that
their body was really beginning to move
back into balance in homeostasis so
gratitude you know the funny thing about
gratitude is that we're conditioned and
hypnotized into believing that we need a
reason to be be grateful now when you
get when you when something happens to
you or something's happening to you when
you're receiving something or you've
received something you feel gratitude
and you say thank you well when you
start to feel gratitude ahead of the
actual experience the emotional
signature of gratitude means it's
happening to you it's already happen
happen to you that gratitude is the
ultimate state of receiving so you can
take a person who's been diagnosed with
cancer say as an example and they're
living in fear and turning that
Battleship around instead of them
surrendering to fear every day you teach
them how to surrender to love or to
gratitude and when they start
self-regulating well their immune system
is going to get stronger we know that uh
and at the same time the thought of them
getting better is going to make it into
the body because the thought is is can
be received by the feeling of gratitude
because the body's believing believing
as the unconscious mind that it's in a
state to receive that something
wonderful is happening to it so you can
begin to program the autonomic nervous
system to work in a very different way
and um and and it takes it takes
practice but um but yes it's entirely
possible and and we and we see we we
measure this and once you know the skill
on how to do this it's it's just like
anything else like once you know how to
do it uh you can do it with your your
eyes open as well as your eyes closed
and you can turn some of those very
strong chemicals that become we become
like addicts you know the it's a drug
you know the arousal of the stress
hormones uh people start to become very
dependent on them and and they use the
problems and conditions in their life to
reaffirm uh this emotional need to feel
these uh feel these chemicals and that
means they become addicted to the life
they don't even like you know and and
and if you can turn on that stress
response just by thought alone you can
become addicted to your own thoughts now
this is this is a challenge for people
because this explains why change is so
hard but by the same means just like an
adct overcoming heroin you're going to
have some Cravings you know you're going
to say hey it's been 2 days since you
suffered I mean come on the hardest part
about change is is not making the same
Choice as you did the day before and the
moment you decide to make a different
Choice get ready it's going to be
uncomfortable it's going to be
unfamiliar there it's going to be
unpredictable there's going to be some
uncertainty you're you're leaving the
known biologically neurologically
chemically hormonally genetically you're
stepping into a River to cross a river
to become somebody else and and when
people really start understanding that
their
personality creates their personal
reality and your personality is made up
of how you think how you act and how you
feel that means then the present
personality who's listening to this show
has created the present personal reality
called her life and if you want to
create a new life a new personal reality
you got to change your personality that
means you got to start thinking about
what you've been thinking about and
changing become aware of your
unconscious habits and behaviors
and notice them and and look at the
emotions that you live by every single
day that keep you connected to the past
and decide you say that we have to
master the concept of the present moment
what does that mean well there's so much
talk about the present moment and being
present in the power of now but um most
people
um they spend the majority of their life
uh 95% of the time either living by some
past emot or some past habit or
anticipating the future based on the
past and so we're very rarely in the
present moment and and paying attention
is being present and it's a skill just
like anything else the more you practice
it the better you get at it so think
about it if feelings and emotions are
the end product of past experiences and
you can remember experiences better
because you can remember how they feel
if you wake up in the morning and you
have to search for The Familiar feeling
called you every morning and and that
feeling is unhappiness or frustration or
lack or insecurity or
fear the moment you get in touch with
that emotion you're starting your day
from the past because the emotion is a
record of the past now if that emotion
is connected to memories that are mapped
neurologically in your brain of certain
people at certain places at certain
times with certain things then the
moment you feel that emotion you
associate that emotion with the past
memory then you're activating circuits
in your brain from the past so of how
you think and how you feel creates your
state of being and thoughts are the
vocabulary of the brain and feelings are
the vocabulary of your body then your
entire state of being is in the past and
most people are living in the past so
their body is their unconscious mind and
it doesn't know the difference between
an experience in their life that creates
an emotion and an emotion that they're
creating by thought alone so the body
it's exactly the same so those emotions
start driving people's thoughts and if
they can't think greater than how they
feel and feelings have become the means
of thinking and they believe that their
thoughts have something to do with their
Destiny than they're thinking in the
past so they're creating more of the
same life and by the same means if they
wake up in the morning and they come
back to their senses and they start out
with the same routine that they did
yesterday and they're going through a
series of routine habits of going to the
toilet making coffee eating breakfast
taking a shower driving the work the
same way then we could say for the most
part a person's future is nothing more
than a replication of the past and
they're not in the present moment and if
they keep doing that over and over again
that becomes a habit and a habit is a
redundant set of automatic unconscious
thoughts behaviors and emotions that's
acquired through frequent repetition The
Habit is when you've done something so
many times the body has become the mind
so for most people their body is
dragging them into a predictable future
and they're on autopilot based on what
they've done in the past and they've
lost their free will to a program
broadening your awareness starts to
create brain coherence and when the
brain starts functioning in a more
orderly and coherent way and it begins
to synchronize in those different
compartments of the brain start working
together there comes a moment where the
two hemispheres of the brain start to
synchronize into balance and the union
of polarity the union of opposites the
union of Duality is called holess and
now we are creating from wholeness
instead of from lack or separation and
this is where it gets exciting because
when a person does this
properly and they can practice it our
research shows that people can change
their brain waves in 1 second in 4
seconds in 5 seconds in 12 seconds and
13 seconds and 19 seconds why because
they understand the process of getting
Beyond themselves so why is that
important for you because up until this
point whether you know it or not you
have been the process of practicing
brain coherence the first part of the
formula and
so when you open up your awareness in
your next meditation I'm going to ask
you as if you had no eyes no ears
no body to feel to smell to taste as if
you were just an awareness I'm going to
ask you to sense this Blackness and I'm
going to ask you to sense its depth I'm
going to say how far can your awareness
go into endless space and all I want you
to do is sense its infinite depth I'm
going to ask you to become aware that
there's infinite Blackness on both sides
of you and all I want you to do is
broaden your focus and to sense it to
feel it to stay connected to it and the
act of opening your awareness in sensing
space slows your brain waves down I'm
going to ask you to become aware that
there's Infinite Space behind you and
the act of sensing that Infinite Space
behind you causes your brain to start to
fire more orderly we've measured this
thousands of times and as if you were
just an awareness in that Blackness I'm
going to say to you now it's time to
become nobody no one no thing no aware
in no time and take your attention off
of everything known into invest it into
the unknown and like investing into a
bank account the longer you linger in
the unknown the more you create
possibilities in your life and if you
find your mind returning to your body to
your pain to your drives to your
emotions to your habits to thinking
about certain people or objects or
places or things in your known
predictable reality to thinking about
the familiar past or the eventual future
simply become aware that your attention
is on the known investing back into this
three-dimensional reality stop relax
return back to the present moment and
unfold back into possibility into the
Blackness we would love for you to speak
into how when we find coherence when we
find alignment between brain and heart
then we can we can Steward whatever
reality we want to us in in record time
yeah so one of the things that we we do
is we we when you're agitated at someone
and on a zoom call and you know you're
doing
the and you're thinking about five ways
to throttle them you know I'm joking but
you get the idea you're aroused by
something that knocks you out of balance
and you're sitting there you know your
heart's beating against the closed
system it's pumping blood but you're not
running you're not fighting you're not
hiding and it starts it starts creating
problems the heart starts beating out of
order out of
rhythm and so we discovered when we
started seeing teaching
people how to place their attention on
their heart when they where you place
your attention is where you place your
and out of all the things that you feel
with you know what I'm talking about
with your body we ask people to feel
with nothing but their heart and where
you place your attention is where you
place your energy and
we we started seeing we started hooking
up heart the the ECG monitors with the
brain and every time the heart would
flux into coherence you would see this
wave of alpha just this beautiful
coherent wave of alpha heart was telling
the brain create and Alpha is the
creative state and when we're in Alpha
we see in pictures we see in images
we're imagining when we're in beta we're
thinking we're analyzing it's the voice
in your head so we saw that when the
person dropped into their heart really
well there was this kind of wave of
information that that went to the brain
and caused the brain to become very
coherent and it was always after the
heart doing was in that state and so we
started realizing that the heart was the
creative Center it was it's when we move
out of these first three centers and we
move into our heart when we move into
that Center The Heart starts telling the
brain starts informing the brain so we
started building instruments with in
with our brain scientists and our and
our scientific team where we could
actually see how this kind of phenomena
worked and so
when a person starts putting their
attention in their heart we start seeing
this uh low frequency this very low
frequency in the heart that's only
indigenous to the heart start to fill up
like a gas tank just the person's just
putting their attention on their heart
and they're giving their heart the
energy it needs to beat that's what that
frequency is about so you're feeding it
an energy so we see it kind of go up
like a gas tank and then we see the
parasympathetic
relaxing right so now they're relaxing
but then all of a sudden we see the
parasympathetic nervous system about to
drop down and here comes the sympathetic
nervous system and other person's having
a little
arousal and we started discovering that
when this occurs when a person is
relaxed in their heart there's energy
that moves to the brain the person
starts seeing possibilities that they
they never saw before and so getting
really good at relaxing in your heart
and Awakening your brain
causes this kind of synchronization that
takes place between the two they're
they're dancing together in this really
beautiful way and when they're uh in the
same or similar frequency uh if you're
sharing the same frequency you're
sharing the same information now the
brain may think but the heart knows and
I'm telling you it is a straight shooter
it does not beat around the bush at all
and now the heart starts telling
informing the brain giving it the
information that the person needs for
themselves in their
lives we can do this we take people we
can train them to do this and they can
do it in 15 minutes and when when they
start getting really good at relaxing
more in their heart and more energy
begins to move into their brain we start
seeing this very crazy thing happen in
the brain where delta waves are now
carrying theta waves and theta waves are
carrying alpha waves and alpha waves are
carrying beta waves and beta waves are
carrying High beta waves and high waves
carrying gamma waves and the whole
entire brain is functioning in resonance
there're patterns within patterns within
patterns within patterns that person is
having a very profound uh transcendental
moment so we work with getting really
relaxed in our hearts and awake in our
brain we do it so much I want people to
get so good at doing it with their eyes
closed they can do it with their eyes
open because relaxing the heart and a
wake in the brain is so much better than
stressed out unconscious and living in a
program there's tiny little calcium
carbonate crystals in the pineal gland
that are stacked up on top of each other
in the human being
rhombohedrons and they're stacked up on
top of each other and the research
says that it has Pio electric properties
what does that mean I looked it
up when you apply a mechanical
stress to these crystals the mechanical
stress begins to create an electrical
charge in the
Crystal and the compression begins to
polarize the ends of the crystal with a
positive charge and a negative charge
and when you polarize the crystal with a
what do you have a
magnet and all of a sudden as you
compress those crystals the mechanical
stress creates an electrical field and
that field actually expands until the
crystals can't stretch any longer and
then the field
reverses and when the field reverses the
field actually exerts a pressure against
the crystals
again that causes the crystals to expand
and the next thing you know you have a
little radio
receiver how many people
understand and you switch on the brain's
radio receiver and now the brain can
tune in the
frequencies beyond the
senses and that is the mystical gland
and the research says it's a transducer
how do I know I looked it up I didn't go
on social I looked it up transducer like
a television
antenna that's what it said taking
energy and information in one form and
turning it into pictures and images
meaning and that's why it's called the
third eye because you have an inner
Vision that's more real than the outer
world the brain now is picking up
information from the field and it's
transducing it into profound imagery a
mystical transcendental moment and we do
the breath when you finish that breath
I'm going to ask you to finish it right
on that pineal Glam that's your Target
and I'm going to ask you to hold your
breath now this is not
torture I'm not asking you to hold your
breath to see how long you can hold your
breath if you're thinking about how long
you're holding your breath you're not
doing it I want your attention as you
hold your breath I'm going to ask you to
lift this up pull this in lock this down
straighten your spine drop down and pump
and squeeze a little bit more and I just
want you to keep squeezing and pushing
that fluid right up against that Target
there
I'll say exhale and then you feel and we
go get it
again I don't feel like it is not going
to do anything I'm too old nothing will
happen you got to leave that behind you
you got to get lost in the
act and when that energy moves I have
had it
happened thousands of times it is big
it's not like ooh I'm an energy worker
it's not like that it's like holy heck
it's a train that's moving and it goes
right up to the
brain and that energy is being released
in the brain and the Brain goes into
those gamma brainwave patterns very high
gamma brain wave patterns let's just say
that lack is ingrained in there you got
the story you lived on the streets you
lost everything you got betrayed your
business partner took everything took
your wife took you got the story in the
half okay okay you got to start telling
a new story of the future right you got
to believe in that future more than you
have to believe in the past so how do
you do that you only believe in the past
when you feel the emotions of the past
the only time you're going to believe in
the future is when you feel the emotions
in the future right okay so in order for
us to change a belief or perception
about our s and our
lives we have to make a decision
with such firm
intention that the amplitude of that
decision carries a level of energy
that's greater than the hardwired
programs in your brain and the emotional
conditioning in your body and your body
literally has to respond to your mind
that the choice that you're making to
change in that moment becomes a moment
in time that you never forget and here's
the key physically physically the
stronger the emotion you feel when you
make that choice the more you remember
the decision okay so then how do we
downregulate that old belief if the
trauma created an emotional quoti of six
or seven then your decision to change
your belief's got to be a nine right and
you got to come out of your resting
state and that moment has to Define you
you could say I know exactly where I was
the time and day it was who I was with
when I made my mind up to change right
cuz you created a long-term memory
long-term memories are created from
strong
but the ude of em iser the Betrayal Boom
the body starts responding to mind
you're actually giving your body a taste
of the future emotionally so you brand
your impossible no your body is actually
getting the taste of that future event
it's experiencing the future now exactly
big explosion on the quantum field big
explosion so the side effect of that is
if you combine that clear intention with
that elevated emotion you're basically
remembering your future and it looks no
different than remembering your past
think neurologically within the circuits
of that memory and feel within the
emotions of that new belief and watch
your life begin to change because
nothing changes in our life that we
change and when we change our energy we
change our life so now the experiment
all of a sudden is no longer based on it
being hard or trying or wishing or
wanting or hoping that's what we do when
we're lack we in lack or separation it's
about change so then when we finally
realized in order for
us to become abundant we have to
overcome the old personality and that's
95% of who we are right yes so then the
side effect of the beginning of this
process is a lot of discomfort it is a
lot of discomfort because you're
stepping outside the known into the
unknown and now you can't predict scary
no no you you'd rather hold on to your
lack the pain suffering rather tell the
story of that at least makes you feel
something that's familiar when you step
outside and you're saying I'm not going
to complain about money any longer I'm
not going to complain about I don't have
any I'm not going to judge other people
who do I'm not going to say I can I'm
not worthy it's never going to work all
those things got to go I'm not going to
feel lack I'm not going to feel unworthy
I'm not going to feel separation I'm not
going to feel resentment these are the
things that are keeping my reality the
same now it's no longer about abundance
about who you become mhm so the
overcoming process becomes the becoming
process process and so many people come
through this work they want abundance
they want healing they want a new
relationship they want a new career they
want the mystical but really they want
wholeness and and they want healing they
want peace they want wholeness cuz they
feel on whole well well when you're in
lack or you're in separation you're not
whole imagine feeling so much wholeness
that's impossible to want that's what
our that's what we're working on with
people then you can really enjoy a
sunset then you can really enjoy a
you can really enjoy your friends you
can I I I I talk to people that are very
abundant I mean in the billions abundant
and you know so many of them say we are
in misery we're not whole we're in agony
because they can't enjoy life anymore
that's what they want I mean people want
abundance to be able to enjoy life they
want to be able to do whatever they want
with whoever they want as many times as
they want wherever they want that's
Freedom right we want abundance to
sponsoring thought is really they want
freedom right or whatever their
sponsoring thought would be right I
think there are many modalities that
work for trauma what I've discovered is
that Insight never really changes
Behavior you can see that your father
was overbearing or was an alcoholic or
you could see all these different things
you know like you could come up with the
Insight all these different things the
problem that I see with people is then
they tend to excuse their
change by saying oh I a rough childhood
that's why I am the way I am they're
excusing their pre present position so
and again trauma's a difficult thing but
for
me the person who's living by the
identity in their life that they were
traumatized as a child or whatever it is
or they've had a trauma in their life
I'm not saying forget the trauma and
create another emotion I'm saying that
the person who's willing to to go
through the
emotion and keep working on lowering the
volume to it the the we have had so many
people in this work with brutal pasts
really really difficult pasts do the
work and finally they reach that point
where they just break free from the
emotion they look back and I have
interviewed enough of them it's the same
thing they look back at their entire
past and they don't want to change one
thing in their past cuz it brought them
to this elegant moment where they're
liberated they see their betrayers they
see their abusers they have nothing but
love for them now the side effect of
that and many times they'll say it was
like my heart blew wide open they had to
pass through the valley of the shadow of
Darkness to get there they just thought
I I don't know if I can go any further
and they went one more
time and the body literally was
liberated from the past right cuz the
trauma is not just in the brain the
trauma is St emotionally in the body so
you want to take the body out of the
past out of the known what do you think
the body is going to say if it's been
conditioned to be the mind the unknown
is a scary place you step out into the
unknown you're going to be unprepared
for that trauma you don't know how it's
going to happen and so the person keeps
clinging to the known and but when the
person finally overcomes the emotion the
body literally is freed from the chains
of the past the side effect of that is
seeing the past from a greater level of
Consciousness lo and
behold there goes the Suicidal
Tendencies there goes the dysfunction
there goes the irritable bowel syndrome
that was because the body was still
living in that past event by living by
the same emotion so the research on
memory is kind of fascinating and I just
I've studied it enough and and
and the way we recount the past is not
the way it happened even if you
absolutely think you remember it being
that way so we don't have the same brain
as we did when we were eight years old
or 12 years old or 20 years old we have
a different brain we have a completely
different brain so the fabrication of
the story for many people they embellish
the story and make it seem even worse
than what it was but you're really what
you're saying is I changed in those
moments and from a biological standpoint
I haven't been able to has change since
so let me tell you why it's been so hard
for me to change and the story becomes
dramatized or
embellished the person Works them up
fire themselves into this emotional
froth and then fires and wires the same
circuits in the brain and they're
actually reaffirming their limitation
now there's nothing wrong with that I
think we're just taking too long right
so 50% of that story isn't even the
truth it means in a sense we're reliving
a miserable life that we never even had
and we don't want but but the but the
the unknown people would rather cling to
their suffering no this is not a
judgment we all do this we'd rather stay
in the known than take a chance in the
unknown because those emotions of
survival are saying what run from the
unknown the unknown is a scary place so
now the unknown you got to come up
against that moment where you're going
to actually leave that behind and step
into the unknown this is not a
intellectual process this is
this is David and Goliath there's a
battle going on where the body keeps
wanting to go back to its familiar State
because it's subconsciously been
conditioned to be the Mind stay in the
known to overcome the
body takes a will that's greater than
the program to to no longer get up and
run through the same routine that you do
every day and your body wants in the
middle of meditation saying quit I'm too
tired you got too many texts you got too
many emails you got too many things to
do the body's been programmed to get up
and go and you and you say way wait wait
wait wait a second here we're not going
anywhere until I get clear on who I want
to be today and every time you execute
that will that's greater than the
program people say oh I'm I can't
meditate actually you're doing it right
actually that's why it's hard because do
it you're actually that is the process
right there there's no such thing as a
bad meditation what you're doing is
actually exactly what you need to do and
every time you do that you become
conscious that you go unconscious that's
how you actually develop the skill of
Consciousness it's not being conscious
it's catching yourself when you go
unconscious and people if they can see
thinking is the unconscious essentially
conscious is connecting to everything
which is in the space of nothingness
really but there's a journey to get
there and if you're patient with
yourself and you see that as a
victory like oh you start getting arous
you start getting frustrated you think I
can't do this and you go oh no no no no
no no no we're not going to quit here
that would be me getting up as the same
person I'm curious what's on the other
side of this frustration you settle your
body back down into the present moment
you unfold back into that Eternal space
I'm telling you every time you do that
it's a victory you're telling the body
it's no longer the mind that you're the
mind then it actually turns out that the
body starts liberating energy it starts
liberating energy but like an unbridled
stallion it goes oh really you think
that's all you think that's all you have
watch this and then it get starts
bringing up me memories of the past and
all of that just to feel an emotion and
if you're aware that it's doing that and
you settle it down you're you're taming
the animal you're teaching it you're
you're teaching it how to change its
state right and guaranteed if you keep
doing that you walk out in your life I
guarantee you'll be less responsive and
reactionary to everyone and everything
so in seven days we see that not only
there are dramatic biological changes to
suggest that the person different
environment but it it goes for the
majority of people that immerse
themselves in going all in and what does
that mean a different environment
they're in a ballroom they're in a
ballroom I've been to thousands of
ballrooms there's nothing really
exciting in a ballroom what's exciting
in a ballroom they all look the same but
the data suggests that they're in a
whole new environment where where is
that where is that taking place it's
taking place from within the person
closed eyed internal world is everything
open because you made it this far in a
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
for 5 hours of incredible Joe despenza
motivation check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there if I take all your attention off
the place you work the place you live
the place you need to be the place
you're sitting and go from somewhere to
Nowhere you got to stop thinking about
the predictable future and the familiar
past and go right into the present
moment and go from some sometimes